Using the genetic code, we see that an insertion
of just one nucleotide pushes everything else out of
frame. Here we had TCA, now we have TTC.
We had TCA, now we have ATC. Sure, we changed
the codon where the actual mutation occurred, but we
also changed all the codons downstream of that, so this
would best be described as a frameshift mutation. Now
some of you may have wanted to put missense and
it's true, you are changing the individual amino acids
for that particular codon. But you're also changing all
the amino acids down stream and so the best
categorization of this kind of mutation is a framshift. Remember
that when we say frameshift. It's implied that all
the other codons are going to get changed, which
means all the amino acids are changing as well
likely. And so we going to have lot's of missense effects
in the over all protein.